this episode of real science is brought
to you by curiosity stream sign up today
at curiosity stream comm slash real
science and get free access to watch
nebula comm on February 15th 1977 a
two-ton steel cage called Angus was
lowered to the seafloor near the
Galapagos Islands it was equipped with
cameras and powerful strobe lights and a
sensor that could detect water
temperature changes as small as five
thousandths of a degree all through the
night Angus took thousands of photos
while researchers monitored the
temperature readings hoping to see a
spike that would indicate that they had
found what they were looking for a deep
sea hydrothermal vent after many hours
of searching Angus finally sent out a
signal it had registered a spike in
water temperature the next day the
scientists developed the 3000 photos
that Angus had taken on its 16 kilometer
journey they studied every single photo
frame by frame until they reached the
photos that corresponded with the time
when the temperature spike occurred all
of the photographs taken before the
temperature anomaly showed only barren
terrain but for 13 frames during the
temperature spike the photos revealed
that the sea floor was covered with
hundreds of white clams and brown mussel
shells this was certainly not what the
researchers were expecting with no light
trickling down whatsoever the deep sea
floor is supposed to be a barren
wasteland thrilled and confused by what
they had just found the researchers
prepared Alvin the three-person deep-sea
research submarine to investigate the
three pilots navigated to the spot where
the temperature spike occurred and what
they found stuns them
coming out of small cracks in the ocean
floor and was warm shimmering water they
had successfully found what they had
hoped to the first ever discovered deep
sea hydrothermal vent but what they
absolutely did not expect to find was a
vibrant bizarre and dense community of
animals thriving there from Owlman the
pilots could see one foot long white
clams thousands of brown mussels and
many strange-looking white crabs later
they found a vent site full of massive
eight-foot tall white stock tube worms
with bright red tops the discovery of
these animals was so surprising because
up until this point it was believed that
the entire planets food chain was
completely reliant on photosynthesis and
that no community of animals could live
without sunlight what were these animals
eating down there
with no sunlight whatsoever water
samples from the vents gave the
scientists their first clue as the
researchers opened up the first water
sample the smell of rotten eggs filled
the room the water was full of hydrogen
sulfide something about the chemicals
coming from the vents was allowing the
animals to live at these depths without
food from sunlight this would be the
beginning of a game-changing revelation
in chemistry and biology that changes
how we think about where and how life
began on earth hydrothermal vents form
in places where two tectonic plates are
separating away from each other this is
why all of the hydrothermal vents that
have been discovered to date over 240 of
them are located on the boundaries of
Earth's plates the vents are a result of
seawater percolating down through
fissures in the ocean crust and the
vicinity of spreading centers then from
pressure and temperature the water is
forced back up and released back into
the ocean and with the water comes many
different minerals which start to
precipitate out once they touch the cold
seafloor
these precipitations start forming
hydrothermal chimney stacks which have
been found to be as tall as 60 meters or
18 stories high they are magnificent
structures founded an average depth of
2,100 meters with the deepest ones being
found at 3,800 meters chimneys like
these are called black smokers and are
formed from deposits of iron sulfide the
plumes emit all sorts of heavy metals
and sulfides stuff that would be
extremely toxic to most creatures and
the temperature of the water coming from
the vents can reach up to 400 degrees
Celsius not boiling because of the
immense pressure at these depths it is
an extremely harsh environment and yet
lifehere thrives the giant clams and
eight-foot bong tubeworms
are exceptionally interesting and
strange creatures but it is in fact a
smaller organism that makes these
ecosystems possible the microbes that
convert the mineral Laden fluid into
energy instead of using light energy to
turn carbon dioxide into sugar like
plants do they use energy released by
chemical reactions of the minerals
spewed from the vents to make a sugar a
process known as chemosynthesis for
reference plant photosynthesis uses the
sun's energy to transfer electrons from
water to carbon dioxide to produce
carbohydrates to create sugar without
the Sun however is a different process
during chemo synthesis the source of
energy is energy liberated from a
chemical reaction the oxidation of an
inorganic substance rather than energy
harvested from sunlight hot water
flowing from the hydrothermal vents is
saturated with inorganic compounds like
hydrogen sulfide the bacteria use energy
stored in the chemical bonds of hydrogen
sulfide to make glucose from water and
carbon dioxide pure sulfur and sulfur
compounds are produced as byproducts
this is the process that allows the
vibrant communities of deep-sea animals
to survive the giant tubeworms for
example live symbiotically with these
bacteria the bacteria lives inside the
worm allowing the worm to utilize the
sugar molecules created these
weird-looking crabs also populate
hydrothermal vent areas in massive
numbers they to survive directly off the
sugars produced by the chemosynthetic
bacteria growing in their bristles other
animals feed off of the clams mussels or
crabs that feed on the bacteria all of
the creatures that form the hydrothermal
vent communities are part of a food
chain made possible by chemosynthesis
our knowledge of chemosynthetic
communities only began with that fateful
discovery of the first hydrothermal vent
communities in the 1970s since then
chemosynthetic bacteria have been found
in hot springs on land and on whale
carcasses and sunken ships at the bottom
of the ocean and their discovery has
changed the entire way scientists think
about the origins of life itself
scientists generally agree that the
origin of life on Earth involved an
evolutionary process of increasing
complexity that involved molecular
self-replication self-assembly and
eventually the emergence of cell
membranes basically that chemicals and
molecules slowly became organized into
nucleated cells however there are many
different theories for exactly how this
could have happened for years a
prevailing theory known as the
primordial soup theory of life was
largely based around Stanley miller's
1952 experiment that demonstrated that
most amino acids can be synthesized from
inorganic compounds
by sending an electrical charge through
a flask of a chemical solution of
methane ammonia hydrogen and water
scientists proposed that an external
source of energy like lightning may have
triggered these reactions in the early
Earth however critics of the soup theory
point out that there is no sustained
source of energy to make inorganic
compounds react and without an energy
source life as we know it couldn't have
come about an opposing theory of life
was thus introduced in 1993 by
geochemist Michael Russell from NASA's
Jet Propulsion Laboratory he suggested
that life came from harnessing the
energy gradients that exists when
alkaline vent water mixes with more
acidic seawater providing the continuous
energy source needed the rationale for
this line of thinking is that life as we
know it is based on the physical
compartment ation from the environment
or the chemical reactions that allow
life to exist happen in a self-contained
environment aka inside of cells
researchers like Russell therefore
hypothesized the inorganic matter that
had similar attributes of compartment
ation could likely be what led to
organic life proton gradients across
cell walls and membranes to create
charge differentials also play an
essential role in life this is known as
the proton motive force and usually
involves a difference of about 3 pH
units across a membrane this is
effectively a mechanism to store
potential energy that can then be
harnessed when protons are allowed to
pass through the membrane to
phosphorylate adp making ATP which is
the chemical that provides energy for
living cells the precursor to life would
similarly need a chemical gradient
across a physical boundary for these
reasons russell proposed that life could
have originated at deep sea hydrothermal
vent chimneys if those chimneys had
pores that could provide a template for
living cells and if there was a 3 pH
unit difference across the thin mineral
walls that separate the vent and
seawater this energy could allow the
reduction of carbon dioxide and
production of organic molecules then
self-replicating molecules like RNA and
eventually true cells with their own
membranes scientists praised this theory
as being hypothetically possible but no
such vent had ever been found
the ones that had been found were not
alkaline in nature and therefore had no
chemical gradient that could be
harnessed
but then in 2000 the missing piece to
this puzzle was found at the lost city
hydrothermal field located in the middle
of the Atlantic Ocean it was different
than the vents that had been found
before this one spewed alkaline water
the lost city vents differ from the
black smoker type event and that they
are located several kilometers away from
the spreading zones rather than directly
upon them because of this the water does
not come in close contact with the magma
chambers underneath the crust it is
instead heated by chemical reactions
between seawater and mantle rocks
because of this the water is only heated
to around 90 degrees Celsius on average
instead of 400 degrees Celsius like in
the black smokers additionally because
of the mineral makeup of the earth
beneath the lost city the vents emit
water that is highly alkaline with a pH
of around 11 the chimney walls are also
full of tiny pores that separate the
warm alkaline vent fluid from the cooler
acidic seawater the interface between
the two create a natural charge gradient
scientists realized that this could be
the pH gradient and compartmental
structure that Russell had proposed
would be needed to allow life to emerge
and while not all scientists agree that
life began in a deep sea hydrothermal
system and there are many kinks in the
details that need to be worked out this
theory of life has big implications for
our world and beyond hydrothermal vents
have recently been found to exist on
other worlds like Saturn's moon
Enceladus a place where conditions might
not only allow for life to exist but to
begin as well
the ocean makes up most of the world's
surface and yet we have explored less
than 20% of it by some estimates in less
than 1% by others it may as well be an
alien world the first-ever photo of a
living giant squid was only taken in
2004 and only four people have ever
ventured to the bottom of the deepest
part of the Mariana Trench called the
Challenger Deep almost 11,000 meters
down for reference 12 people have walked
on the moon I think most can relate to
the call of the fascinating dark depths
of the sea for the amazing things that
have been discovered and for what still
remains to be seen you can learn more
about the fascinating expeditions to the
deep and the amazing animals that have
been found there by watching deep ocean
narrated by David Attenborough on
curiosity stream curiosity stream is a
streaming platform that has thousands of
high quality high budget documentaries
the deep ocean series explores how
researchers are uncovering the secrets
of the Mariana Trench studying newly
discovered deep-sea animals and their
quest to uncover the oceans most ancient
creatures and to make it even better
your curiosity stream subscription now
also comes with a subscription to nebula
the streaming platform made by the best
educational content creators like
Wendover productions tears you real-life
lore and our other channel real
engineering nebula is a place that
allows creators like us to make exciting
original content without worrying about
the YouTube algorithm or the
monetization there are so many episodes
and shows being added all the time like
city Beautiful's new series on the
planning of ancient Rome that traces the
rise of the city that spawned an empire
or working titles or different creators
break down the intros for their favorite
TV series or real engineering z' and new
logistics of d-day series which tracks
the strategy and decisions that led to
the Allies successful invasion of
Normandy on d-day
so if you sign up using the link below
you'll get access to all of curiosity
stream and all of nebula for just $19.99
a year and be supporting a community of
creators that love making new and
exciting content
[Music]
you